good evening everyone my name is sue
chard Lowe and I'm a software engineer
I'm going to talk to you about how I
switched careers when I turned 40 so
tonight I'm going to cover how I decided
I wanted to be a coder how I made the
leap and what I learned along the way I
actually started coding about 35 years
ago long before I doing the police so
here's me and my 13th birthday the
greatest potted home computing
enthusiast they're almost camouflaged
against the carpet I had to learn from
books because we didn't have the
internet then and also there was a
program on BBC two called the computer
program and I've actually tweeted out a
link to all the episodes if in case you
wanted to have a look so it was really
exciting growing up in the 1980s we had
films like wargames that this is still
from war games with Matthew Broderick
and even films like Ferris Bueller's Day
Off which Matthew Broderick was also in
he hacked into the system to change his
grades and his girlfriend's grades and
you could actually code at home there's
a lot of famous tech founders from that
generation people like Chad Hurley of
YouTube
Sam Yaga of OkCupid were born within a
couple of years of me and the difference
is that they kind of went the path of
tech straight away and I kind of went
the long way around this is the computer
that I learned to program or and it's
called a BBC microcomputer it's a
British invention created by Akon
computers and it was part of the BBC
computer literacy project and it
accompanied the TV show that I mentioned
earlier it's really easy just booted it
up typed in your code and the way you
went and you saved all your programs on
the cassette disk you could get a
destroy but you had to plug it in most
of us had cáceres and you had to plug it
into the TV we only had a one TV in the
house so you couldn't just code whenever
you wanted to you had to either book a
time we just have to fight particularly
to get your time on the TV
we did have IT lessons at school but the
teachers kind of just looked up what
they needed to teach us just before
lesson they weren't really that
interested in it so they would come to
me
help with the lessons I went to a girls
school and they didn't offer GCSE or
a-level computing my brother went to the
boys school which was kind of twinned
with a girls school and they did offer
GCSE and a-level computing but when I
was 12 I won the school prize for IT and
this is a letter from the guy who
donated the prize which is a 10 pound
book token and I we've got 10-pound book
so can i bought a French book and a
German book so I was just about to start
learning for our languages and what I
find really interesting now looking back
had that letter from October 1990 is the
way he speaks about how languages are
going to become more important in Europe
so thinking back to how it was then and
now it's quite interesting to see so
after a few years the the shift went
from home tinkering with computers and
coding them to being a user so we we
still have the BBC micro but then we
switched to or 386 PC and when I switch
that on Arthur I don't know how to
program this and that's kind of where I
stopped doing the programming this is me
and my best friend Jenny still best
friends now on our last day of stick
form like you can see we're really happy
we're 18 we're leaving school we're
going to uni but we didn't know what we
wanted to do when we grew up I never
consider computing as a career hand on a
DCC hand on the a level the distance
seems to be a path didn't occur to me so
I went and did a business degree and
then went straight into working in
marketing and that was around the time
when like yahoo and Alta Vista and Ask
Jeeves are kind of coming up and people
were getting dial-up modems at home and
people starting to use the Internet at
home so I taught myself HTML in
university so really I've got 23 years
worth of web development experience
I worked my way up from marketing
assistance marketing executive and then
got a job as marketing manager as well
IT consultancy and in all my jobs I
proactively looked for opportunities to
do web development partly because I was
interested in it partly because nobody
else understood it and they didn't
really want to do it so it kind of came
down to me I was working at this little
IT consultancy they had a tech team
there was one women on there and maybe
about 12 to 15 men and they'd all taken
computer science degrees and I looked at
them and I thought I know how am I going
to make that jump across the divide I
honestly do not know how to get into
tech here so then one day they told me
right you're going to be your jobs gonna
be made redundant and I was really upset
I was in my mid-twenties and this has
never happened to me before
I just made my way up to marketing
manager I thought that my career path
has mapped out and then suddenly I was a
spanner in the works didn't know what to
do and there was just this feeling of
rejection and failure
so I brushed myself off and got a job at
the Met Police I worked in the IT
department doing their marketing so
again I thought ok great I'm near tech
now I can make this job but I didn't see
anybody that I aspired to be like they
by their own admission a lot of them
weren't technical so they had a lot of
service and what they've done was they
come in when they were young and then
just stayed there and then they just
moved into these tech roles and also in
the Met Police what they do is they
manage the relationships between the Met
Police and the outsource providers so
they don't actually make stuff
themselves so it's may be there that I
could go out to say how they hey how did
you do this but I did ask one woman who
had about 20 years service how she got
her senior tech role and she replied to
me that she's working the police station
and then one day they brought this
computer into the police station like
one computer in the 1990s and because
she was the only person that could type
they said right you can be the computer
person and then you know ten years later
she's in the senior IT role I was like
okay so I can't relate that I'm really
puzzled about how I do this
there's a lot of cuts in the places you
you may have heard
a lot of government cuts and that's
affecting the police a lot so my job was
made redundant again I came out of the
marketing went into a role where I was
overseeing surveillance jobs and things
like that's really interesting and then
got a job in logistics but because I was
a senior manager because of all the cuts
I found myself having to constantly
manage teams that were going through a
lot of change and the change was stuff
that was really important to them so
it's things like where they were working
the hours they were working and the
sauce they were doing and I was going
through the similar changes myself and
it's really hard to try and bring people
along and that change while you're going
through it yourself they're never going
to be happy and you know that as a
senior manager that's what your career
is going to be like because they're not
going to pump those of extra money to
the police suddenly so I knew that I
needed to do something so I thought okay
what can I do and then why did I choose
to do coding so I had to think long and
hard about this I knew that what I've
been doing before I was okay out but it
wasn't really me so I thought long and
hard about it and I knew that I needed
more options to kind of future-proof my
career and also knew that I did couldn't
figure out how to cross the divide so I
thought about like you know what did I
enjoy doing when I was young looks at my
hobbies I really enjoy creating things
and making things that people use and
enjoy I looked at what I enjoyed about
my career so far and you know like
creating efficiencies communicating with
people and making tools so I was always
the one that would go into Excel and
then make a little tool for people to
calculate how much annual leave they had
because they couldn't do it on a bit of
paper things like that I went to meetups
to come meet other people in the
industry and try and get an idea of how
I could do that journey went to
hackathons won my first hackathon even
though I did not know how to code and
spoke to friends in the industry so I've
got quite a lot of friends in the
industry most of them are male
but then they went the route of right we
did the a-level computing we got the
degree in computing and then went up so
that was helpful and not helpful so how
did I learn well like I said I've taught
myself HTML when I was at university did
some online courses I learned from Bert
and then I found out about coding boot
camps so then I applied for a place on a
pending recap I went back to the
classroom what I did was I applied for I
didn't do a drastic change I decided I
was going to take a career break from
the police which meant that my job would
still be open after the boot camp so I
just took some unpaid leave from the
police and then after the boot camp took
some time out and then went back and
when I was on the boot camp I found that
I was with like-minded people they all
wanted to improve themselves
it was strange coming from the police
because the environment that we were in
everyone just felt like there was no
hope for them but when we're on the boot
path
everyone was really excited it was
really intense from day one we were
doing things that we'd never seen before
and there was no more right-click open
in browser a graduated from the boot
camp with three full stack JavaScript
applications and my portfolio which you
can see on my website there SUSE dev I
was amongst the oldest there and as you
can see there was probably like five or
six women in the group for two to one
mentor women and the photo of us is on
day 60 of 60 so that's the very last day
of our boot camp so I went back to the
met after that and then they said to me
right you're gonna be made redundant and
this time I was really happy because I
wanted to leave anyway and I thought
right so they're gonna give me a bit of
redundancy pay to leave so I took their
dancing then I left the met after 12
years so am i doing now well I decided I
needed a break from work I was also
going through you a bereavement so that
was even more a reason to take a break
so I'm now on a guilt-free career break
I'm researching roles and industries I'm
still going to meet up some networking
still hacking going to the hackathons
volunteering I'm organizing meetups as
well I can't I don't know how I had time
to work up [ __ ] in the first place doing
my hobbies practicing my skills at
hackathons and also on my website which
I've recently relaunched and also
started blogging one of the things that
I've done recently as well as I've been
offered a job to teach
on how to code which sits really well
because I've been in the scouts for five
years so I've got a bit of experience
with children and unless it should help
me to kind of solidify my knowledge
because I'm sure they can ask me loads
of questions for that I can never even
thought so finally what did I learn
along the way apart from how to code
well I learned the programming
principles are basically the same as
they were 35 years ago so you've still
got all like the loops and the variables
and things like that it's just the
language is so different and the
machines that you're using they're
different another thing that I learned
is nothing was as scary as I thought it
would be I left the place police after
12 years and nothing bad happened at all
another thing that I learned was some
people just don't understand it and not
everyone is going to encourage you but
don't let that put you off because I
think a lot of the time it says more
about them than it does about you a
horse I found out that the tech
community is generally speaking is quite
open welcoming and sharing or I found
from the meetups and the hackathons also
you don't need a degree so you know when
I was met all those people at the
beginning a lot of them had degrees or
they'd just fallen into it in the police
and then I realized actually you don't
need one and because you don't need one
you can actually make that switch quite
quickly I've also realized I've got a
lot of transferable skills from my 20
year career before I became a software
engineer as well which is come in very
handy at the hackathons where I can't
code but it turns out I'm quite good at
speaking of the client and getting from
them their requirements and what they
really need and what they think they
need which is something I had to do
marketing all the time and also learned
that all all code is Google stuff
doesn't matter how experienced the haha
they all have to google it and even the
most experienced of them suffer from
impostor syndrome so that is my journey
to programming via policing thank you
very much for listening
you